nos dicen que la escala en el plano de
una casa muestra que diez centímetros
representan dos metros cuántos metros se
están representando con 18 centímetros
en el plano pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolver bueno lo primero que
debemos saber es que un plano es un
dibujo a escala de algo en el mundo real
en este caso es de una casa entonces
vamos a ver del lado izquierdo voy a
poner el plano esto corresponde al plano
y del lado derecho pondré el mundo real
ahora las unidades que usamos en el
plano están en centímetros
aquí tenemos centímetros pero en el
mundo real usamos metros
haré una especie de tabla vamos a ver
nos dicen que 10 centímetros en el plano
corresponden a 2 metros en el mundo real
entonces 10 centímetros en el plano
y después nos preguntan cuántos metros
se están representando con 18
centímetros en el plano entonces a qué
corresponden 18 centímetros del plano en
el mundo real bueno existen varias
formas de resolverlo una forma es que
para pasar de 10 a 18 necesitamos
multiplicar por 1.8 así que para pasar
de lo que esos diez centímetros
representan en el mundo real a lo que
representan 18 centímetros necesitamos
multiplicar por 1.8 y 2 por 1.8 es igual
a 3.6
punto 6 metros en el mundo real
entonces 3.6 metros en el mundo real es
lo que representan 18 centímetros en el
plan hagamos otro ejemplo
jazmín dibujo una gallina con una escala
en donde cada dos unidades de su papel
cuadriculado representan seis
centímetros en el mundo real
la gallina es de 16 unidades de altura
en el dibujo cuál es la altura en
centímetros de la gallina real
nuevamente pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolver bueno nuevamente
pongamos nuestra tabla primero tenemos
el dibujo y después tenemos el mundo
real ahora en el dibujo solo tenemos
unidades unidades y en el mundo real
pensamos en centímetros
ahí está pongamos el resto de la tabla
entonces aquí podemos ver que en esta
escala dos unidades representan seis
centímetros en el mundo real
entonces dos unidades en el dibujo
representan seis centímetros en el mundo
real y después nos dicen que la gallina
es de 16 unidades de altura en el dibujo
entonces en el dibujo tiene 16 unidades
pero eso que representa en el mundo real
es decir cuál es la altura real de la
gallina bueno si dos unidades
representan seis centímetros y ahora
tenemos ocho veces estas unidades
entonces esto representa ocho veces la
cantidad de centímetros que ya conocemos
así que 6 por 8 es igual a 48
centímetros por lo tanto cuál es la
altura real de la gallina claro 48
centímetros
centímetros hemos terminado nos vemos en
otro vídeo